welcome back to our series on embedding
looker previously we walked you through
our private embedding option
now let's dive in and get you started
with our other option SSO embedding with
the embed SDK
this option allows you to embed your
looker content in an iframe however
unlike our private embedding option your
user can securely view the embedded
content without manually logging into
looker via SSO or directly
the embed SDK also manages the iframe
HTML element for you
in this video we'll go through the basic
information you need to get started
we'll cover the SSO embed URL the SSO
embedding flow and the embed SDK and
code samples
but first a Quick Knowledge check
you should understand the iframe HTML
element
JavaScript looker access control and
permissions management and the concept
of authorization and Authentication
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first let's look at the SSO embed URL
so how does SSO embedding allow your
user to securely view embedded content
without manually logging into looker
well at a high level SSO embedding uses
a one-time use URL set on the iframe
source
we call this the SSO embed URL it
contains information about the target
look of content you want to embed the
user access permissions and other
information that determine what your
user can do during an embed session
when your user accesses your embedded
content with the SSO embed URL
looker automatically logs in your user
as an embed user with the permissions
provided in the URL
one way to look at it is to think of SSO
embedding as URL based auth as opposed
to UI based off with our private
embedding option
so
how do we create this SSO embed URL
well you can create it manually
but we provide a convenient API endpoint
on your looker instance to generate it
it's called create SSO embed URL
we will refer to this API endpoint
throughout this video
so let's look at some basic parameters
you need to pass into the endpoint to
generate the URL there is the target URL
parameter
session property parameters like session
length embed user permissions parameters
like models permissions and user
attributes and the external user ID
parameter
first let's start with the target URL
parameter this is the same URL as the
embed content URL mentioned in our
previous video on private embedding
this points your iframe to the looker
content you want to embed with the right
settings applied like dashboard filters
now let's talk about the session
property parameters these properties
Define how the session behaves for
example the session length parameter
determines how long your user can stay
logged in
next let's discuss the parameters
covering embed user permissions
you must pass in these permissions so
your user can access and interact with
your embedded content
for example the model's parameter
determines what models your user can
access
the permissions parameter determines
what your user can do in the session
like viewing a dashboard or creating an
alert
the user attributes parameter helps
govern your users data access
but lastly the most important parameter
you need to consider is the external
user ID
when your user accesses your embedded
content looker logs in your user
automatically as an embed user which is
also called an external user
you must Define an external user ID on
your SSO embed URL so looker can
associate your user with the correct
embed user
if the external user ID does not match
any existing embed user ID
then looker logs in your user as a new
embed user with the permissions and ID
defined in the URL
typically you should use your host
application's user ID as the external
user ID we've now walked through the
basic parameters you need to pass in to
the create SSO embed URL endpoint
the endpoint will return the SSO embed
URL for you to set on your iframe Source
attribute keep in mind each SSO embed
URL you generate is unique and can only
be accessed once by your user
check out our documentation to learn
more about the SSO embed URL and what
other parameters are available to
generate the URL with our API endpoint
now let's walk through the SSL embedding
flow we want your host application to
securely embed your local content in an
iframe for each of your users
your host application well
create an iframe generate the SSO embed
URL for your user and then set the URL
on the iframe source attribute we'll
walk through a high level architecture
example of how your host application
could implement the SSO embedding flow
architecturally we will focus on three
parts
your host application front end
your host application backend and your
looker instance
alright let's get started with your user
first your user logs into your host
application your host application
backend authenticates and authorizes the
user
next your host application front-end
creates an iframe
and then requests from the backend the
SSO embed URL to set on the iframe
then that request to your backend
triggers a downstream request to your
looker instance your backend determines
what permissions your user should have
and which embed user your user should
map to
then your backend calls to create SSO
embed URL endpoint with the parameters
we previously discussed next the looker
instance generates the SSO embed URL and
returns it to your host application
backend
the back end Returns the URL to the
front end and it sets the URL on the
iframe source
with your looker content now embedded in
an iframe your user accesses the
embedded looker content
when this happens looker starts a
session with the permissions and
properties provided by the SSO embed URL
and logs the user in as an embed user
after that keep in mind looker expires
the URL
so let's say your user's session ends
and they return to view your embedded
content your host application must
generate another unique one-time use SSO
embed URL
to set on the iframe
and there you have it we've walked
through a high level architecture of the
SSO embedding flow we hope that gives
you a basic understanding of how you can
implement it
let's discuss how the embed SDK and our
code samples make it easier for you to
implement the SSO embedding flow
let's look at that flow again our embed
SDK automates the steps where your host
application front end creates the iframe
request the SSO embed URL and sets the
URL on the iframe source
for example let's say you want to embed
a dashboard
you initialize the embed SDK with the
looker instances domain and your
backend's endpoint that Returns the SSO
embed URL
now let's configure the embed SDK to
build your iframe you call the create
dashboard with ID method with the ID of
your dashboard so the SDK embeds the
correct looker content
next you call the append to method to
tell the SDK where to insert the iframe
into your host application Dom
now with this basic configuration
finished you call the build method
the embed SDK automatically fetches an
SSO embed URL from the endpoint you
configured then the SDK creates an
iframe with its source attribute set to
the SSO embed URL and then the SDK
appends the iframe to the specified HTML
element
now your host application front end has
an iframe pointing to the SSO embed URL
in addition we provide code samples
linked below to help your host
application backend call the create
embed SSO URL API endpoint
keep in mind the embed SDK can do much
more than what we've covered you can
discover more embed SDK functionality in
its depository
links below Alright good job folks we
have walked through the SSO embedding
with the embed SDK option we outlined
what parameters are needed for your SSO
embed URL an example architecture of the
SSO embedding flow and how you can
Leverage The embed SDK and our code
samples to make implementation easier
check out our getting started
documentation link below for more
details on the SSO embedding with the
embed SDK option with that look forward
to more videos in this series where we
get you started with embedding looker
see you next time
[Music]